I'm in love your name has been in so
many headlines lately boom
which I feel like your career since the
first time that we talked has just
obviously exploded because of Outer
Banks but to see your name in so many
headlines really focused on you
introducing the world to Mariah and
saying that you're pansexual I've been
like for you first of all I think it's
awesome I mean I didn't do I've been
really open about it the entire time so
now everybody knows and that's nice and
I've gotten a lot of messages of people
saying I inspired them to come out just
sick and a lot of people are like oh I
thought I was bi but now that I didn't
know what pansexual was so now I realize
I'm pansexual I'm like welcome to the
club yeah you're like welcome to the
world yeah the timing to me I know that
you're saying that like you've always
been super open but the timing of this
really coming to the forefront of the
public I think is super special because
it is Pride Month yes I just want to
know what does Pride Month mean to you
and will you do anything to celebrate
yeah I think I've just been focusing on
talking about it as much as I can um
pride pride is special because I
experienced my very first pride in
Atlanta it was a really good yeah like
really my first time being surrounded by
solely my community and I feel like I
was I learned so much not just like
about other people's sexuality and
gender but also my own of like kind of
finding a name for everything because I
feel like a lot of pan people are the
same that's just like I mean if you want
to call it anything I guess the name is
pansexual but like we're just kind of
like whoever's like
call it whatever you want I want to talk
about that tick-tock
because yeah everyone did kind of freak
out and and a lot of people I guess
don't know or didn't know what pansexual
meant so from your perspective like what
should we all know I think it's just
it's crazy that I'm pan and I feel like
I've been paying forever yeah but I
didn't really know what it meant either
and basically just loving people for
people regardless of gender or any type
of sexuality any type of anything really
I don't know how I could explain it when
then did you realize that you were fluid
or that you were pan kind of take us
back to that moment yes so I guess um I
dated or I was 18 I was like yeah I'm
gay and then I was like I still like
boys so I guess I'm bi so I just like
went on for a couple months
spewing our guy was bi and then I worked
with trans boy on a show and we dated
for a good while and I was like okay so
what does that means I guess you're
Pamela okay guys I'm panicked
it's kind of slow I just like realize
that I kind of the same thing that my
fans were figuring out of like oh I
thought it was by but I didn't realize
that that was excluding so many people
hope the only reason I say I'm pansexual
is just like to make the inclusivity
very clear I love that you said you've
always felt very supported in your
sexuality a lot of people have not
though like they don't have that support
system so what do you say to those
people of the lgbtq+ community that have
felt hatred or felt discriminated
against or I felt just had a hard time
like sharing their feelings
I yes I said this before that I had a
very easy coming out everybody was
really cool about it but I'm not blind
to the fact that I'm very lucky to have
those people in my life and have the
parents I have you know if you're safe
come out we want you here but you like
you know your surroundings more than I
would I I've said this multiple times
and if you don't feel safe to come out
and you're worried then maybe wait until
you are safe and make sure but people to
people who are dealing with and are
struggling with the backlash and the
hatred towards it you have a community
that loves you if social media is a
great outlet you will find people you
will no matter what kind of person you
are in the world you will find your
person and you're always safe and
welcome with me how did you tell your
parents and how old were you I was
scared to tell my mom my mom's from
lower Alabama and she's cool very very
sweet person but some part of me is
still nervous sometimes you feel a
little more unsafe than you actually are
and so I waited until me and my mom were
already in a fight now is the perfect
time like you don't even know anything
about me I'm being really
melodramatically playing out a scene you
know my mom was like what don't I know
about you I was like you don't even know
I've been dating a girl for a month and
she goes in the thickest southern accent
there ever was go fun
Madison be gay I just what so hard not
to start laughing I was like
is honestly the funniest reaction I can
think of fun not a simpie gay like I
don't I don't care yeah your dad he goes
I know my mom told her like my sister's
family yeah yeah no surprise anybody I
[Music]
do want to talk about Mariah that's okay
with you I love how giddy you just got
first of all when did you guys meet and
how did you meet we met I'm sorry we've
probably been talking and in
communication for a month in there okay
so this was was this after then the show
came out um yes it is so she actually
posts in a dick talk and I saw it and I
immediately I was like this is the
cutest person I've ever seen in my life
I have to I've defined her I have to I I
went I found her Instagram I followed
her I got on one of her lines and did
you guys communicate solely through
social media at first before you
actually met in person yes completely
social media and then I was like hey
let's hang out I am on the East Coast
and was like where are you she's like
I'm in Charleston I was like you're
lying to me right now like there's no
way she's like 20 minutes away truce
holds on I had no idea so what did you
guys do the first time you hung out we
just hung out we just I was staying at a
hotel in Charleston at the time and I
was like just come here no we can just
chat everything's closed so yeah just
hang out and then yeah and then she she
just came out to LA she's never been out
here I just never float alone I actually
dropped her off at the airport this
morning which is it was it hard to say
bye to her how long we
here for impossible to close to two
weeks okay so it's only really been a
month and a half but do you feel like
it's serious I mean you guys are very
serious and I had zero hesitation to
post on social media about it I was like
her as a human being I was like no
matter what happens like you will be in
my life forever like I care about her so
much I care about her family her
family's incredible just as a person
just a very genuine genuine person was
that a conversation that you had you
know should we put this on social media
here's what could happen it might blow
up and you didn't expect every single
news outlet to it was everywhere yeah
did she how did she feel about that she
was like take it at your own pace she
was like I don't you can post whatever
okay now this is that quick quick
conversation yeah what what is it about
her that you were so attracted to um
she's a very soft person she's a very
gentle hearted and very kind she's very
loving and you see that and like the way
she loves basketball the way she loves
her family and you see like her loyalty
and dedication and things that she cares
about I'm getting emotional well that's
how it should be though it's like I mean
alright are you in love I'm in love I'm
sorry you're gonna make me cry I just
like I love love so much and I love you
I love love as your family met her yes I
should after
[Music]
I will soon I yeah I was in North Korea
up to North Carolina and she was driving
up to Charlotte the same day to stay in
her dorm and to see people that she
hadn't seen in a while and then I was
like I'm only like two hours away from
Charlotte and she drove to my family's
house met everything Maggie yeah and
then I went back to Charlotte with her
and like metal her friends and then move
out from Charlotte to LA the next day so
this was like a very instant connection
then absolutely did she watch Outer
Banks she did watch Outer Banks they did
before she met you were after she met
you before
did she say that she like had a crush on
you or anything on the show yeah yeah
that's why he made that okay that is so
funny when are you gonna see her next
what's that plan like I told her I've
never gone a month without seeing her so
tentatively sometime in July whenever
I'm free and have a moment yeah yeah how
will you guys handle the long-distance
just like a lot of face times and text
um I think I think it'll be pretty easy
because both of us are gonna be busy
she's going back to school um in July so
she's going to be busy she's gonna be
doing yeah okay things yeah because of
the platform that you have now do you
feel a responsibility to talk about
sexuality and social issues and to help
educate people
yeah I I definitely enjoy it cuz I don't
feel like it's very pressured on me
nobody was like Madison you were the new
face of I feel like I very much took it
upon myself and it's less of like here
I'm a professional in here I'm going to
educate you it's more just like
here's what I'm doing with zero fears
and I hope that it can empower you I do
want to talk about mental health but I
also want to talk about you made a
comment in your Instagram live and you
said that you don't believe in straight
people you're like they're unicorns and
I'm just curious like what you think
like do you think it's a spectrum
I was IBM's today of homophobic Miss
jumping out people being offended that
they would even I would hold my beak the
thing would be I was like okay calm down
Emily yeah I had somebody be like um
they're like that is so rude I would
never say that if I to invalidate you if
I believed in pansexuality and then in
parentheses put which I don't I was like
all right I think I definitely made it
more of like it is a spectrum take their
time to figure it out yeah they're just
like not that there aren't straight
people but there's just a bare plate
statistically too many
you mentioned earlier mental health and
I know that you've talked about being
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder which thank you also for
speaking out about that why was it
important for you to share that I feel
like it helps I feel like it's such a
huge part of who I am and I really do
want people to be able to get to know me
I'm not shy I thrive in transparency and
also like I can't think I didn't have
anybody to look up to not that wasn't
like a medical professional like I said
this a thousand times
I am NOT a medical professional I don't
understand like the science behind
mental health I can't pretend to know um
I should further educate myself but I
think it's also really important to
speak from a voice of this is just
something I'm going through it's not
something that I know everything about
I'm figuring it out day by day on my own
so that was a very important platform
because I didn't I didn't have anybody
like that cuz I'm not I've said this I'm
not a therapy person I'm very internal
with the way that I like to deal with
things I like to self-educate on a lot
of things and I know that there are a
lot of other people who feel that way
same thing with why I speak so much
about like other ways to deal with
mental health that aren't therapy
because therapy isn't for me it's never
something I connected with probably my I
like an authority figure from something
like that stranger about all my problems
and I just I was gonna say like did you
have a bad experience in therapy ever um
no it was just I didn't feel like I
benefited from it I feel like I got my
diagnosis and that's what I needed I
needed a word to call it other than
crazy and I got that and
figured it out because then I started
realizing my own triggers because
they're all different everyone's
different and I know issue my therapist
like you can do group therapy so you
know you're not alone and I'm like I
drop but I'm not alone it's just like
everything about that gave me more
anxiety and I know a lot of other people
feel that way of like what do I do when
I don't want to be on medication or
don't want to go to therapy like well
there's some things you can do within
yourself to take care of yourself when
were you diagnosed with BPD um I was 17
or 18 okay what had been going on it
made me really sad when you said people
like they call it crazy and it's like
it's not crazy yeah literally not and I
think it's it's just frustrating that
people call it that of course yeah
definitely a word that's been pushed on
really anybody struggling with really
anything instead of other people
admitting that they're human beings it's
somehow easier to call people crazy I
don't know and I don't get it
I think it was just picking up on the
consistencies it's noticing patterns and
noticing certain triggers not being able
to calm yourself down for me personally
I there are a lot of pros and cons to my
disorder I'm discovering all of the pros
which I'm very thankful for but what are
some of them some of the pros of having
a personality disorder a lot of one of
the main things is that likes and
dislikes change often so my aesthetic
changes often my music taste changes
often so you gotta say I'm like I don't
like this I like it later it's just for
right now
no I got a lot of different phases so I
feel like I have a very broad
personality which allows me to connect
with a lot of people being sensitive was
such a hard thing I cuz that's another
one of the main components of this
disorder is having
an exposed nerve to every emotion and
every feeling but I think the bright
side of that is that it allows me to
connect with so many more people I'm
able to put myself in other people's
shoes very easily and deliver empathy
with authenticity how is it working I
mean I just think of like onset and I'm
just curious how that yeah I think
acting has been a good outlet because on
days where it's really hard to be myself
it's really easy to be somebody else
flippin that's which it like once you
call action my problems will be waiting
for me whenever he calls cut you know
what are the best ways that you have
found to cope well there are different
types of things that need different
things um a lot of a lot of self-care
all of this the self-care you know like
taking that time for yourself yeah
medicating it's a huge one for me a lot
of people talking about Oh Maddie and
her crystals I think a huge part of the
reason I like crystals is because it's
given me a better understanding for
emotions
it's compartmentalizing what I'm feeling
and I think that's something I really
benefited from it like yeah less about
this is going this is gonna solve all my
problems and more about like making me
be mindful of what how do you and Mariah
lean on each other and like support each
other with what each of you guys are
going through I don't know much about
her but yeah both of us are very good
listeners just communication both of us
are good at communicating things and we
even really had many issues I mean like
she needs anything like I'm here and
we're both able to know when to vocalize
what we're feeling and also when to
prioritize the other person like you
found that balance very naturally
[Music]